bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france une expérimentation à rennes
plutôt qu'un moratoire c'est une bonne
façon c'est vrai vous d'appréhender la
5g
alors concrètement pour moi il s'agit de
faire du clientélisme électoral
c'est-à-dire que la maire de rennes et
un higuain ayant été élu avec des pois
d'europe écologie sur lequel sont très
sensibles sur le thème ça lui permet de
faire on va dire plaisir à une étrange
lectorat en lançant une espèce de
consultations avec des études dont on
sait que vu la durée elles pourront pas
voir une conclusion au niveau sanitaire
qui soient pertinentes que juste avant
une idée est malgré tout aujourd'hui
toutes les études existantes montre qu a
pas de risque majeur c'est vrai que
étant donné que c'est la bretagne je
pense que les gens doivent être très
préoccupé que la 5g perturbe les ondes
des cercles de pierres ou je ne sais pas
que c'est un dommage les dolmens ça
paraît ridicule mais aujourd'hui
effectivement on a dépassé le stade de
la raison n'est donc on est dedans on va
dans le pur émotionnel et c'est vrai que
là dessus
lancer ce genre de consultation
paradoxalement ça donne corps aux
critiques de ceux qui veulent dire la
technologie est forcément aussi l'or ça
veut pas dire que j'ai pas dire aucun
problème avec la technologie
ça veut dire qu'il faut garder raison
est que le vrai sujet pour moi sur le
développement de la 5g et de toutes les
technologies avancées dont devraient
planifier ses technologies au niveau de
l'état on devrait le mutualiser des
antennes sert pour éviter une
prolifération des antennes ce qui a
aujourd'hui puisque chaque opérateur
pour son antenne on devrait on va dire
avoir une planification sur le temps
pour éviter justement un renouvellement
trop rapide des technologies et
pérenniser les technologies et
aujourd'hui on voit être la crise
sanitaire
on fait la promotion du télétravail
avoir un état qui contrôle
on va dire le développement de ce type
de technologie sale régler le problème
des zones blanches
qui aujourd'hui font qu'une partie de
nos concitoyens ne peuvent pas aller
travailler
donc je pense qu'il faut rester
raisonnable et que ce genre d'initiative
a vraiment un pour but de faire plaisir
nick toi plutôt que d'avoir une réalité
sur le ca va rien changer concrètement
et les conclusions probablement seront
un conclusive et les gens resteront
convaincu que soit c'est nocif soit
c'est pas nocif les dreads les
détracteurs de cette technologie de la
5g aujourd'hui pointe du doigt notamment
la multiplication des antennes qu'est ce
que vous répondez à cela elle c'est un
peu ce que j'évoquais juste avant c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui durée une solution
simple on le fait pour la télévision
c'est à dire qu'il ya un opérateur
unique qui était à vendre l'état mais
malheureusement été privatisé qui
étaient des êtres qui envoie les
fréquences pour tous les chaînes de télé
aux etats unis c'est pas qu'à chaque
chaîne de télé avec une antenne en
france on a été intelligente pour la
télé de faire ça alors on peut très bien
le faire pour les téléphones portables
d'ailleurs on voit pendant très
longtemps on a essayé de nous dire que
la possession des antennes étaient une
plus value et on va dire c'était quelque
chose d'important pour les opérateurs
or certains opérateurs comme free par
exemple à l'étranger ou même en france
vend ses antennes à d'autres opérateurs
puisque ce qui leur importe c'est
d'exploiter les antennes puisque les
antennes en elle-même donc effectivement
on pourrait très facilement diviser par
quatre le nombre d'antennes puisqu'on a
quatre opérateurs et donc mieux couvrir
rationaliser l'investissement et surtout
mieux développer le territoire là dessus
puisque c'est toujours les grandes
villes qui vont avoir les technologies
en premier et aujourd'hui encore des
zones où il n'ya pas de 3g en france on
parle d'années déjà 5 g il ya des zones
où il ya pas 3g
donc c'est vrai que là dessus je pense
qu'il faut avoir une logique une
réflexion sur le long terme et aussi
parce que réellement plus on continue à
se développer certains coins puis une
fracture numérique qui se remet à dieu
qui s'installe parmi nos concitoyens et
d'ailleurs est justement cette crise
sanitaire
la différence entre les cadres urbains
qui pour local télétravail est très
facile et d'autres individus pour lequel
c'est quasiment impossible faute de
connexion de qualité parce qu'on n'a pas
encore la fibre partout alors que ça
devrait déjà le cas merci d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à nos questions
pedro bonne et au responsable numérique
de la république slovaque